[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ولد القارئ احمد سعيد الفرشوطي في مركز
فرشوط بمحافظه قنا المصريه لعائله قرانيه
فوالده هو الشيخ محمود الكحكي الفرشوطي
مدرس القران ومحفظه وعلى يديه حفظ الفرشوت
الابن القران الكريم كاملا في سن مبكره
قبل التحاقه بالمدارس الازهريه ومنها الى
كليه الشريعه والقانون بجامعه الازهر
الشريف باسيوط التي تخرج منها بتفوق قبل
التحاقه اماما وداعيه بوزاره الاوقاف
المصريه
انا حفظت القران الكريم في سن مبكره جدا
والفضل يرجع لله اولا ثم لوالدي فضيله
الشيخ مسعود والذي لا اعرف قيمته ولم اعرف
قيمته الا بعد ان توفاه الله سبحانه
وتعالى كان حريصا على ان يعلمني كتاب الله
سبحانه وتعالى وكان حريصا على ان يكون
واحدا من ابنائه يحمل كتاب الله سبحانه
وتعالى ويكون داعيه للاسلام والمسلمين بعد
ذلك يعني انت تعرف الشباب
انطلقت الى اللعب ولا له ثم بعد ذلك تفلت
مني القران بعدما حفظته في سن مبكره لكن
الهمني الله سبحانه وتعالى الى ان ارجع
للقران مره اخرى وكان ايضا في سن مبكره
كنت في ساعتها
في سن السادسه عشره
حفظت القران الكريم كاملا باحكامه
وبتجويده حفظا متقنا ثم بعد ذلك والدي
عليه رحمه الله كان كثيرا لمراجعه القران
الكريم كان يومه كاملا من الصباح الى ان
ينتهي يومه كان ينتهي يومه كان في خدمه
كتاب الله سبحانه وتعالى وكان يقول لي يا
بني تعالى واقرا معي كنت اقرا معه ثلاث
اجزاء يوميا اربع اجزاء او اكثر الى ان
امل انا ولا يمله يقول لي اقرا اقرا لانه
طبعا يراجع لي كتاب الله سبحانه وتعالى
والفضل يرجع لله اولا ثم اليه بعد ذلك لم
اكن اعرف شيئا عن شيء عن شيء يسمى اجازه
القران الكريم
فاكرمن الله سبحانه وتعالى في بلدتنا شيخا
يسمى الشيخ عاصم عبد الغني النجار
عليه رحمه الله سبحانه وتعالى كان له فتحا
كبيرا في بلدتنا فرشوط حيث تعلم على يديه
الكثير من ابناء المركز وخارج ابناء
المركز وحصلت على يديه على اجازه حفص
للقران الكريم
وكانت هذه انطلاقتي مع الاجازات في القران
الكريم
اخذت معه ختمت اكثر من ختمه على يديه ثم
بعد ذلك
كان الله سبحانه وتعالى يعني يناديني على
لكي اخدم كتاب الله سبحانه وتعالى
بدات وشرعت في تعلم القراءات مره واثنين
وثلاث ولكن
اتعسر بدات مره ثم تعثرت بدات مره ثم
تعصبت لان من شروط اجازه القراءات في
العشر الصغرى
ان يحفظ الانسان متن الشاطبي والدره
ومتن الشاطبيه الف بيت
بالاضافه الى متن الدره 216 بيت
فكان الشيء هذا كثيرا عليه ولكن شاء الله
سبحانه وتعالى ان يسهل لي الطريق فقال
لاحد الزملاء
واسمه فضيله الشيخ طه الشيخ قال لي اني
ساذهب الى الشيخ وكان خارج البلده
هل تذهب معي لكي نقرا عليه القراءات قلت
هيا بنا واخذت معه الميعاد
وصباح صبح الصباح وذهبت معه الى شيخنا
الشيخ معتز عبد الفتاح النجمي من ابناء
مركز ابو تشت ايضا من محافظه قنا
وقرات عليه القراءات العشر الصغرى جمعتها
وقرات عليه متني الشاطبيه والدره بفضل
الله سبحانه وتعالى وهذا كان طريقي معه
ايضا
لكي يكون مفتاحا الى ان اقرا على يديه
ايضا العشر الصغر الكبرى
وكان هو الذي يشجعنا على ذلك انا كنت قلت
الحمد لله انتهيت من العاشر الصغرى هذه
القراءات
وساعلمها
لابنائي مركزه فكنت اعلمها للابناء سواء
كانوا بنات او بنين كانوا يقراون على يدي
الكثير من القراءات ثم جعل يحفزني لكي
اقرا عليه القراءات العشر الكبرى
فقلت كهذا كثير علي فضيله الشيخ فقال
استعن بالله سبحانه وتعالى ولا تعجز وكان
اذا يراني اذا انقطعت عن القراءه كان هو
الذي يتصل عليه ويقول لي اقرا ولا تكن
كسول فكانه كان يعاتبني فكنت اقرا عليه
مره واثنين وثلاث الى ان انتهيت منها بفضل
الله سبحانه وتعالى هذا بالنسبه
لمجالي في القران الكريم
تعينت كما قلت لك في بلده مركز فرشوط في
محافظه قنا ثم بعد ذلك
راوا مشايخ بلدتي الى ان امسك واتولى
واخدم اكبر مسجد في بلدتنا يسمى المسجد
العتيق
وهذا المسجد له فضل كبير بعد الله سبحانه
وتعالى عليه حيث كنت انقطع فيه
القراءه وتعلم القران وختمت فيه في
التراويح ختمتين وكنت اقرا القران فيه في
الصلوات بدايه من البقره الى ان انتهي الى
سوره الناس واخذت ختمت ختمه بقراءه
الكسائي وختمت ختمه بقراءه ورش
وكنت ساختم ختمه اخرى الى ان يعني اخذني
الله سبحانه وتعالى الى القاهره
ذهبت الى القاهره
ثم اكرمني الله سبحانه وتعالى لكي اكون
خادما لمسجد سيدنا الامام الشافعي بحي
الخليفه في اداره جنوب القاهره وهو من
المساجد المعروفه الاثريه والذي يدفن فيه
سيدنا الامام الشافعي جزاه الله عنا وعن
المسلمين خير الجزاء وهذا المسجد يرتاده
الكثير من السياح ومن الاجانب لانه من
المعالم الاثريه يدفن فيه الملك العادل
ويدفن فيه الامير شمس ويدفن فيه محمد بن
عبد الحكم
وحتى لا انسى فضل اهل هذا المسجد علي
كانوا يكرموني غايه الاكرام
وكانوا يفرحون حينما يجدون اماما صعيديا
معهم
ويعني اكرموني غايه الاكرام وبارك الله
فيهم اقراوا عليكم قراءه
بروايه الامام الكسائي من طريق الشاطبيه
وسيدنا الامام الكسائي
رحمه الله سبحانه وتعالى من الائمه الكبار
في القراءه
وهو ايضا من الائمه الكبار في النحو
وهو من ائمه الكوفه يعد من القراء
الكوفيين
يقول عنه الامام الشاطبي ثم ابو علي
الكسائي نعته لما كان في الاحرام فيه
تسربله
اقراوا بحول الله وعونه وتوفيقه من اول
سوره القيامه
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
لا اقسم بيوم القيامه
ولا اقسم
بالنفس اللوامه
ايحسم الانسان ان نجمع عظامه
بل قادرين
على ان نسوي بنانه بل يريد الانسان ليفجر
امامه يسال ايان يوم القيامه
فاذا برق البصر
وخسف القمر
وجمع الشمس والقمر
يقول الانسان
يومئذ اين المفر
كلا لا وزر الى ربك يومئذ المستقر
ينبا الانسان
يومئذ بما قدم واخر بل الانسان على نفسه
بصيره
ولو القي معاذيره
لا تحرك به لسانك لتعجل به
ان علينا جمعه وقرانه
فاذا قراناه فاتبع قرانه
ثم ان علينا بيانه
كلا ابد تحبون العاجل
وتذرون الاخرين
وجوه
يومئذ الناظرين
الى ربها ناظري
ووجوه
يومئذ باسره
تظن ان يفعل بها فاقر
كلا اذا بلغت التراقي
وقيل مره
وظن انه الفراق
والتفت الساق بالساق الى ربك يومئذ المساق
فلا صدق ولا صلي
ولكن كذب وتولي
ثم ذهب الى
اهله
يتمطى
اولي لك فاولي ثم اولي لك فاولي
ايحسب الانسان ان يترك سدي الم يكن نطفه
من من تمي
ثم كان علقه
فخلق فسوي
فجعل منه الزوجين الذكر والانثى
اليس ذلك بقادر
على ان يحيي الموت
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بعد رحله في الامامه والوعظ والارشاد تمكن
القارئ احمد الفرشوطي من التفوق ضمن نخبه
من الدعاه بالظفر بخطه مبتعث الى الخارج
وهي الفرصه التي تتاح للقارئ للانتقال الى
البرازيل في رحله جديده واجه فيها مجتمعا
مغايرا ونمط حياه مختلف عم عاهده في بلده
الام حيث يتولى الامامه والخطابه والتدريس
القران الكريم لابناء الجاليه المسلمه
ويقدم دروسا توعويه تتناسب مع خصوصيات
المسلمين في مجتمع متعدد الاعراق والاديان
والثقافات
بدايه دعوه في مجال الدعوه لم اكن مستعدا
له ولكن والدي عليه رحمه الله كان يحب ان
يكون واحدا من ابنائه في الدعوه الاسلاميه
فلما نزلت مسابقه الاوقاف قدمت فيها
واكرمني الله سبحانه وتعالى ووفقت في
الامتحان وكنت خائفا هل ساقبل ام لا اقبل
فسالني احد
لجنه الاختبارات في نهايه من امتحنني في
القران والسنه والحديث والسيره والفقه
فقال لي
اخطب قل لنا خطبه يا عم
فانا لم من بدايه حياتي الى ان ذهبت الى
الامتحان لم اخضم خطبه في حياتي
فقلت له لم اخضم
قبل ذلك قال يا عم اعتبر انه في المسجد
فيها يكون
في جنازه او في حاله وفاه ونحتاجك الى ان
تخطب
فماذا ستقول فاكرمني الله سبحانه وتعالى
والهمني كلاما عن الموت ذكرته له
ساعتها كنت اقول له اما بعد فان الدنيا
راكبها الدنيا راكبها مسروع وطالبها مخدوع
وباغيها غاوي وكاسيها عار وجعلت استرسل
عليه بكلمات اكرمني الله سبحانه وتعالى
فكانت كانها علامه باني سانجح في هذا
الاختبار
بعد ذلك كان كل ما تنزل مسابقه في الاوقاف
للتراويح كنت اقدم فيها ويكرمني الله
سبحانه وتعالى اكرمني الله سبحانه وتعالى
ايضا ونزلت مسابقه في الاوقاف لاحياء
ليالي رمضان في بلده رومانيا ووفقت فيها
وذهبت الى دوله رومانيا في مركز الهلال في
العاصمه بوخارست
وفي سنه 2017 ثم بعد ذلك
تدرجت في المسابقات في وزاره الاوقاف
وخاصه في هذا العهد الذي ياخذ الانسان حقه
فوزير الاوقاف يقدم حاليا العناصر
الشبابيه
اهل الاكفاء من الائمه الدعاء وانا اقلهم
كان ياخذهم لكي يمثلوا الوزاره في مختلف
نواحي العالم
ولذلك نجد في بعثه البرازيل اغلبهم الحمد
لله يحملون شهادات الدكتوراه والماجستير
واغلبهم على درايه وعلى يدعون الله سبحانه
وتعالى الى طريق الله سبحانه وتعالى على
بصيره
قدمت في مسابقه الايفاد
للافاده الدائم الذي يوزع فيه الائمه
الناجحون
الى مختلف نواحي العالم
فاكرمني الله سبحانه وتعالى ونجحت في هذه
المسابقه وكنت الاول فيها فرشحني وزير
الاوقاف محمد مختار جمعه معالي الوزير الى
ان امسل البعث المصري في مدينه البرازيل
في ولايه ساو باولو
وكذلك ايضا حتى لا انسى مؤسسه الاتحاد
الاسلامي البرازيلي والذي يرعاها ويرعانا
ايضا الاستاذ الدكتور محمد الزغبي كذلك لا
يبخلون علينا في اي شيء في هذه البلده من
اجل ان نخدم دعوه الله سبحانه وتعالى
اتيت الى المسجد هذا واستقبلني
الاستاذ حمزه ابو محمد رئيس الجمعيه
الاسلاميه ومعه ابو ماهر ايضا في مطار ساو
باولو
ولم يشعروني باي شيء لم اكن غريبا وسطهم
وانما استقبلوني واكرموني غايه الاكرام
وما زالوا الى الان
يوفروا لي كل ما اطلبه الامام هنا في
البرازيل او في مسجده
يعتبر عمده مكانه هو الذي يحل المشاكل اذا
حصلت مشكله في
منزل او في اسره من اسر المسلمين يدعونه
لكي يحل هذه المشكله
وهم بسطاء
لكن
نحتاجهم الى ان يقربوا الى بيت الله
سبحانه وتعالى لانه هو الذي يحل مشاكلهم
كذلك
نذهب الى بيوتهم
نعلمهم القران الكريم نصلي معهم في بيوتهم
لان المسجد في هناك اسر بيتها بعيد عن
المسجد فاذا لم ياتي هو نذهب نحن اليه
نسال عنه
ونساله كيف حاله مع دينه صليت الصلوات
الخمس ام لا قرات شيئا عن القران ام لا
علمت ابنك شيئا من كتاب الله ام لا هذه
امور يحتاجها الانسان لان الانسان حينما
ينغمس في الامور الماديه وفي الحياه القلب
يقسو فاذا لم يجد انسانا يذكره بالله
سبحانه وتعالى يذهب
وينصهر مع غيره فاذا لم نذكر انفسنا بالله
سبحانه وتعالى وبديننا وبقيمنا وبمبادئنا
فان هويتنا الاسلاميه ستضيع اقرا ايضا
مقطعا
بروايه ايضا حفص عن عاصم وهي الروايه
المشهوره انه كما قرات بالكسائي
ساقرا بروايه حفصه عن عاصم
واسال الله سبحانه وتعالى العون والتوفيق
من سوره الانعام
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
وعنده مفاتح الغيب لا يعلمها
الا هو
ويعلم ما في البر والبحر
وما تسقط من ورقه الا يعلمها
ولا حبه في ظلمات الارض ولا رطب ولا يابس
الا في كتاب مبين
وهو الذي
يتوفاكم بالليل ويعلم ما جرحتم بالنهار
ثم يبعثكم فيه
ليقضى اجل
مسمى
ثم اليه مرجعكم ثم ينبئكم بما
كنتم تعملون
وهو القاهر فوق عباده ويرسل عليكم حفظه
حتى
اذا جاء احدكم الموت توفته رسلنا وهم لا
يفرقون
ثم ردوا الى الله
ثم
ردوا الى الله
مولاهم الحق
الا له الحكم وهو اسرع الحاسبين
قل من ينجيكم
لاتمات البر والبحر تدعونه
تضرعا وخفيه لئن ان جاءنا من هذه
لنكونن من الشاكرين
قل الله ينجيكم منها ومن كل كرب ثم
انتم تشركون
قل هو القادر على ان يبعث عليكم عذابا من
فوقكم او من تحت ارجلكم او يلبسكم شيعا
ويذيق بعضكم باس بعض
انظر كيف نصرف الايات لعلهم يفقهون
البعثات التي تاتي من جمهوريه مصر العربيه
منها فريق تابع للازهر الشريف وفريق تابع
لوزاره الاوقاف ولكن كلهم تحت قبه الازهر
الشريف كلنا تعلمنا من الازهر الشريف بعثت
الجمهوريه جمهوريه مصر العربيه في
البرازيل تتكون من طناشر مبعوث
وهم يعني ياتون على احسن اختيار
يذهبون الى الامتحانات امتحانات في غايه
الصعوبه
يعني يصفون على اعلى درجه من الاختبارات
في شتى المجالات في القران
وفي الفرق وفي العقيده وفي المذاهب وفي
الفقه وفي اصول الفقه في الحديث وعلوم
الحديث في التفسير وعلوم التفسير في
السيره في الثقافه العامه
تسال ويختبر الانسان في شتى المعلومات
وبعد ما يجتاز الامتحان التحريري كذلك
تجرى معه اختبارات ايضا مثلها امتحانات
شفويه
وتكون على اعلى درجات الصعوبه
والموفق او الذي يريده الله سبحانه وتعالى
لكي يجري الخير على يديه او من يكتب له
نصيب لكي يخرج يكون ناجحا في هذه المسابقه
بعثت الجمهوريه بعثت الوزاره الاوقاف
تتكون من 12 مبعوث
منهم من يحمل الدكتوراه وهم كثر
ومنهم من يحمل الماجستير
وعلى راسنا رئيس البعثه فضيله الدكتور عبد
الحي سرحان ايضا الذي يقوم على رعايتنا
وعلى كافه امور راحتنا
ينتشرون معظمهم في بلد مدينه ولايه ساو
باولو
موزعين على المساجد وفي احد الزملاء فضيله
الشيخ علي في الامازون في فمعنى فضيله
الشيخ منصور في بارانا
هذا اغلبنا اغلبنا هكذا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]